[Music]
so at a $300 price point there is no
game included in the SKU so you know are
we look at every launch uniquely as to
what's the right thing to do for that
launch you know with the range of
software that's coming not only
available day one but through April into
the summer concluding in the holiday
timeframe with Super Mario Odyssey that
we wanted to enable the consumer to buy
the software they want to look to get to
the most approachable price point we
could get to and that led us to a $2.99
price point and let the consumer decide
what game they want to buy our games the
first decision that we make is where do
we want to be in terms of the hardware
price point that's going to be
approachable and hit the market place we
want and from us price point we want it
to be at $2.99 and then it's all about
what's going to be included you know
obviously the inclusion of - joy con
critically important all the right
cables the dot critically important and
you know we also have to do this from a
financial perspective as well and once
we once we got to that bundle it really
needed to be a $2.99 without a piece of
software it will be and and we see that
just from from a launch standpoint so
we've announced that for example zelda
has an MSRP of 59.99 1/2 switch as an
MSRP of $49.99 and so again we look at
the value of the software and what it
represents to make sure that it's a fair
value back to the consumer
Nintendo switch we've said that two
million units will go into the
marketplace for the month of March so
that initial amount of volume that's a
huge amount of money two million units
on a global basis we're working to make
sure that the supply chain is robust and
there's a steady flow of hardware the
one piece we can't anticipate is the
demand side of the equation but
certainly from a supply we believe we're
going to be well-positioned we have not
shared a lot of information regarding
Virtual Console we will be sharing more
information at a later date
what I can tell you is that with the
introduction of Nintendo account we now
have the capability to tie consumers
purchases to their particular account so
that opens up a range of executions for
us to address that consumer that
consumer desire and that consumer deem
so we hear it we're working on it more
information to come the smartphone app
that we're creating that will be part of
our online service we believe is going
to be a very compelling part of the
overall proposition because that's how
you voice chat that's how you'll do your
matchmaking and create your Lobby we
also think it's a very elegant solution
because if you've taken your switch on
the go you've put yourself in a hot spot
and you're looking at get a quick match
of Mario Cart in to whip out some sort
of bulky game or headset is a bit of a
challenge so we think we've got an
elegant solution that's that's a very
specific answer to your question
I'm taught not to get into the
hypothetical because you know
fundamentally anything is possible from
a Nintendo perspective the way that type
of execution would work would come down
to the developer and would come down to
the type of content they want to create
you know certainly we pride ourselves on
what we've done in the past with the
sharing of one card amongst multiple
devices that's done through a wireless
network so we certainly have a lot of
experience with the ability to do that
with the Nintendo switch
we haven't commented publicly on that
I'm not going to do it here but
certainly again we understand the desire
for something like this and it's
something we have historical experience
my personal experience is that the game
loads faster on Nintendo switch that the
movement through this brand this brand
space is more fluid on Nintendo switch
it's more than just frame rate I mean
literally it's the it's the way you move
through that environment and just how
how the environments just are fluid
versus you know we use a frame called
cop ins right you know I don't see that
when I experience it on antenna switch
and so I am NOT an engineer I can't
speak too technically you know what are
the foundations of the Wii U execution
versus the Nintendo switch execution
what I can say is I play to both their
it they're a great game I'll buy it on
we have been criticized for our online
experience and I'm being gentle and you
know what it's done is is challenged us
to really think about what it is that we
want to create what do we think is best
for the consumer and then also think
through the economics of then how do we
do this
servers aren't free what's necessary to
execute our vision isn't free so it was
those two points right what is it that
we want to create that we think is going
to be meaningful for the consumer how do
we do it in a financially appropriate
way those two came together as a
subscription service and you know more
information is to come in terms of the
full range of benefits that the consumer
is going to get and also will disclose
the price at a future day what I can
tell you is that the Nintendo mentality
of making our products approachable and
mass-market ready and affordable is
going to carry through as we look at the
execution for our online service we
thought deeply around why the Wii U
wasn't as successful as we wanted it to
be and at its heart I would say there
were two issues that we looked to solve
for Nintendo switch the first was the
clarity of the consumer proposition
Nintendo switch is a home console you
can play anywhere with any clear
compelling
the second piece of learning with Wii U
was having a regular cadence of critical
launches to drive the install base and
to keep the consumer base engage Wii U
will go down as having fantastic content
the issue was as you look at the reality
of exactly when the games were launched
there were large gaps in between with
the lineup of Nintendo switch with the
games that are coming out call it within
the first you know 30 days of launch 45
days of launch with Zelda masterpiece
one two switch brand new concept Mario
Kart 8 deluxe the definitive version of
that game that's compelling what comes
next what comes next is arms and
splatoon what comes next after that well
then we're getting into the timing for
Super Mario Odyssey and third-party
content there's our robust steady
cadence of content that was critical for
us to achieve so earlier today I got ass
about mother3 maybe you're gonna ask me
about Metroid I'm a huge Metroid fan
look again I am proud as an executive
with Nintendo to say that we look at all
of the boards and all the comments and
we really have a good understanding of
what our consumers want and believe me
we take that to heart as we work to
create content so I have nothing to
announce here but you know we are aware
that there are some key IP that
consumers just can't wait for the next
true installment in that franchises
legacy
and suffice it to say we're aware of it
and and you know talk to me in a year
and let's let's look back and see what's
happened